c'était la veille des vacances de noël
et la fête battait déjà son plein on
voyage en famille et on a des missions
des vins différents mamour axe pitié
toute la famille est partie faire son
voyage de rêve tout le monde est sorti
on s'en va en oubliant une toute petite
chose maman papa on peut le blé ils
doivent même pas savoir que je suis là
ouais ils doivent ne pas savoir que je
suis là
ma famille c'est hier à tokyo je me
retrouve carrément tout neuf
[Musique]
est ce que tu te rends compte qu'à cause
de toi j'ai mon fils de 10 ans tout seul
à la maison d'arrêt simplement supposer
que max était dans le premier avion
coûte on sait par compte et
je veux pas atterrir en taule je ne
tiendrais pas 30 secondes objets quand
tu arrives en taule c'est là qu'on colle
aucun de nous deux n'a finira
on est des criminels alors ça d'un vrai
c'est ma maison je dois la défendre
la boule orange dans le coup du milieu
vu le bruit ça du fermage
excusez moi je dois rentrer
pour retrouver une piscine
tu es tout seul
qui a besoin de moi
maman j'ai raté l'avion ça recommence
non mais seul tu crois que je suis idiot
ce point
[Musique]
présent non exclusivement sur dix
seraient plus